so after you are a participant in any of
the programs on
omixlogic we invite you to join the omix
research symposium
and participate in the discussions about
cutting-edge bioinformatics how to join
different programs get
prizes and also get feedback from
expert judges so if you could please
also share the link to the august
symposium
somali can adjust me so after
you are welcome to take a look at this
symposium now the symposium is going to
start on august 21st and 22nd
we have a lineup of great speakers
including
dr sona vasudevan who is the director of
the georgetown university master's
degree
program in systems medicine dr gus
casullus
who repre who is the president of the
national association of idea principal
investigators but also the head of the
department
at louisiana state university in
virology and biotechnology
dr lena brodsky who is the director of
the talbot bioinformatics research
center at university of haiti in israel
dr philip compero who is the assistant
department head
at carnegie mellon university
dr chris taylor who is the director of
the louisiana biomedical research
network
bioinformatics core and is
a professor at louisiana state
university health sciences center
okay what are they going to be talking
about they will discuss
bioinformatics cutting edge research and
applications in bioinformatics
where is this field going we're going to
be talking about single cell
multi-omics integration quantum
computing
machine learning and artificial
intelligence translational
bioinformatics how is it used in
clinical research
clinical data integration how are
pharmaceutical companies using
bioinformatics today
we will introduce undergraduate master's
and phd programs in bioinformatics at
university of haifa at university at
georgetown university
at carnegie mellon university at
louisiana state university
at louisiana state university health
sciences center and others
we will also have recruiters that will
speak to you about
industry internships and job
opportunities using bioinformatics so if
you do want to
get an internship remotely or in person
if you would like to explore
what does a career bioinformatics really
look like
you will get a chance to interact with
those people as well
you will find effective resources for
training and education so we will
present
case studies around outcomes from
training so bioinformatics is a
challenging field
not only is it something that takes a
lot of time but it's a challenging field
and so we will talk about that as well
and we will have prizes for best
school college and citizen science
research project so
if you have a project and you still have
time
you have about a month to submit and
potentially get a price for the best
presentation or at least get recognition
so everybody that joins the competition
will have a certificate for joining and
participating in the competition
for those of you that will win the price
it will be a monetary price so you can
use that money
buy a new laptop or even uh you know
take a break from work for a while so
this is something that i'm
really excited and looking forward to
okay so
finally i want